[Music]
Chicago's a city that's famous for its
blues unfortunately a lot of young
people aren't familiar with the Blues as
an artform
I wanted to introduce them to this great
musical genre so I sat down with a group
of first graders at the Francis Xavier
ward elementary school right here in
Chicago and we learned a lot together
check it out
this what we're gonna do we're gonna
play the Blues today and you guys are
gonna help me write some Chicago blues
songs
does that sound fun we do to write the
blues you write about something that's
making you unhappy and by singing about
something that makes you unhappy it
makes you feel better or makes you feel
much worse so what I want you to do is
think about something that kind of
bothers you about your everyday life
summer what makes you kind of grumpy
when I think about how my sister took my
teddy bear when I was probably three
your sister took your teddy bear when
you were three so she took your teddy
bear how long did you keep it for well
actually she said like just begged I
cashed it wait a minute your story's
changing you went from your sister stole
your teddy bear which is a great blues
song by the way to your sister didn't
really take your teddy bear just pushed
your teddy bear off the bed and you
caught it I'm gonna be honest with you
summer this isn't the most terrible
story I've ever heard and I've heard
some bad things what's that
you have any things in your life that
make you irritated sometimes like a
brother that bothers you or kind of food
you don't like edamame wow we didn't
even have it a mommy when I was a kid
that's a food that kids don't like that
was invented in sisterlove so this is
the great tragedy of your life my sister
and my mother eat edamame and I don't
like it quite as much as they do that's
a blue Sun right there in fact it's been
recorded in 1948 a little-known label
that went to funnel all the songs are
about edamame people at my table teased
me because I don't get chocolate you
don't get to have chocolate with
chocolate on one space since I have cold
lunch otherwise this is there any day
you're allowed to have chocolate Oh
Friday that's dessert dad at school so
yeah one of the greatest things about
the blue is one of the greatest themes
is the man keeping you down and this is
the man keeping you down and you're
suggesting
[Laughter]
[Music]
every time I open up my lunch box I feel
just fine
[Music]
[Applause]
don't chop it on a Tuesday
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
on Friday it's the one sole exception to
the rule what do you know about the
Blues in the middle of talking and then
you bent over backwards you almost split
in half does that happen to you
sometimes you're talking to someone and
all of a sudden your lower back just
gives out that's young
7 is young to have lower back failure
what what bothers you when you go to
school um later on we go and we try and
play but we on the end of talking about
what we want to do and then schools are
early leave so you never even get a
chance to play because you stand it
further
[Applause]
your brother's annoying what's your
brother's name Joshua Joshua what does
he do better noise um he wants to do a
bond in my neck
he threw a ball at your neck yeah did it
hurt yeah what did you do um I just felt
Urkel on the way to old was over
that's my defensive strategy as well
that's what I always do when attacked I
fall to the ground and wait for it to be
over a lot of times somebody does a slam
dunk in the ball it's right on my head
I'm noticing that a lot of your fears
involve a ball striking your head or
your neck people just always throwing
balls at you sometimes over the fence I
think if a kid right now in China threw
a ball but somehow land on your head
wouldn't you don't wanna go to China I'm
afraid that I'll say a word that mean
something mean and English and then I'll
get beat up wow that's a very original
fear congratulations
[Music]
cause everywhere I go in this cruel
world
I was getting hit in the head with a
ball
[Music]
pretty cool guy aren't you leo
yeah do you have any brothers and
sisters
yeah are they nice to you yeah
I think sometimes not so nice to you
yeah this police interview will be over
shortly we just need to ask you a few
more questions sometimes he throws stuff
at me was he throw at you there's a boy
I was talking to and everyone's always
throwing a ball at him he's in my class
is anything nathanael everywhere he goes
if the space shuttle released the ball
in space and it fell on her it would hit
a nathanael on the head it would just
kind of like hurt for a second right and
it was like get like if you get hit by a
softball yeah I don't get softball it's
softball but the ball is that soft at
all this is a Seinfeld routine this is
incredible that was great that was
observational comedy I'm gonna get you
in a comedy club tomorrow you should do
ten minutes on this it's really funny
it's good what's with these softballs
they say they're soft but when they get
hit with them they really hurt what's
with that
[Music]
my mom is
[Music]
the news
the children of Chicago's Francis Xavier
ward schools go guys
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]